how's this laptop only twenty seven
hundred dollars with this amount of
hardware built in
what is the catch well today i will let
you guys know everything with my review
of the main gear vector pro laptop
featuring amd's best mobile processor
the 5900x and rtx 3080 with 64 gigabytes
of ram and 2 terabytes of ssd all for
2700
i'll be talking about the positives as
well as some limitations and give you
guys a few tips on how to make the most
out of this laptop now with that i'll be
comparing it to the razer blade because
that is the other laptop that we've been
testing with an rtx 3080 and showing you
guys the benefits of both now that one
is a lot more expensive it's 3 400
and it comes with half of the ssd and
half the ram along with a limited rtx
3080 so you guys will see the
performance compared with both of these
systems now before i jump in i want to
thank microcenter and amd for sending us
this laptop to make this review micro
center has 25 stores nationwide with an
impressive variety of electronics from
gaming vr computer parts like processors
graphics and everything else needed to
build a pc they also have a huge variety
of desktops laptops and all the
accessories that you need not only that
but highly trained staff and low prices
check out a local micro center today to
get your hands on a wide variety of
products before purchasing or use the
link down below to check out the vector
pro at microcenter.com they're also
giving away a free 240 gigabyte ssd to
new customers so go ahead and get all
the info using the link down in the
video description getting started with
hardware on the left hand side we have a
microphone and a headphone input along
with a usb port and then on the right
hand side we have two more usb type a's
we have a micro sd card reader and on
the back we have a beer plug for the
charger we have an hdmi port and an
ethernet port it's pretty rare to see
ethernet built in but it is really nice
to have along with hdmi
and i actually do like that it's on the
back because you can keep it out of the
way when you're using the laptop and you
will need to keep this laptop plugged in
which i'll talk about in just a bit now
as far as the setup up here the keyboard
is surprisingly good at first it just
felt a little bit weird to me but when i
got used to it i was typing fast and
accurate and the trackpad that is about
average it is a diving board design and
i ended up using it with just the
tapping method and with that it was
pretty responsive and with that the
build quality is surprisingly good as
well this is really lightweight they
designed it to be light and at 17 inches
it is only five pounds making it only
0.2 pounds heavier than a 16 inch
macbook pro and onto the screen i was
really happy to see windows hello built
in i love being able to log in quickly
without having to use my fingerprint or
typing in a password now below that we
have this 17 inch screen it is a matte
display so there's really no issues with
reflectivity as with the razor and it's
also that same 400 nits but without that
glossy cover now it's not a 4k display
it's a 1440p display which does save
some battery life i'll talk about that
in just a bit and it is also a 160
hertz so it's super smooth great for
gaming and one thing that i was really
kind of worried about was the
color accuracy of the display but it is
a 100 srgb panel so if you're doing
photo or video editing you can trust
looking at this display so overall i'm
surprised that i would actually take
this screen although i do like the 4k
resolution just because it's a much more
usable display you don't have to worry
about the color accuracy shifting when
you adjust brightness and as far as the
webcam and microphones well you guys can
hear and see it for yourselves the
webcam is not great it's not the worst
i've seen though but the microphones are
pretty bad so i would suggest using a
different microphone if you're going to
be zoom conferencing the same thing goes
for the speakers they're decently loud
but the sound quality just is not great
at least if we're comparing it to
macbooks or even the razer that thing
lacks bass but it does still sound
better of course with that it's just
showing us that this machine here is
designed to do two things one be very
powerful and two
pretty much meet a low price point
especially for that performance so with
that let's jump into performance
one thing i want to mention is that
there is no thunderbolt port on this amd
system but as far as performance i was
surprised that our 200 gigabyte transfer
actually finished faster than with the
razer the razer ended up throttling the
slc cache ran out on the ssd and it took
longer even though i had a thunderbolt
connection compared to just usb type-c
and those ssds are really fast in that
raid zero mode and they are fully
upgradable their m.2 ssds as is the ram
so if you want to upgrade in the future
you can do so now for simple tasks and
web browsing this machine flies through
it that 5900 hx is super quick
so no issues there but if you go ahead
and unplug it and use it as a laptop i
saw a dip of about 25
in order to save battery life now that
does suck to lower up the performance
but compared to that razer it was
actually much faster and had less
performance drop full cpu performance is
also very good close to our m1 max and
an i9 while using less power than the i9
and with that i want to mention the fans
this cooling system works very well but
it is also very loud especially out of
the box so we had no thermal throttling
we're in a full 60 watts the whole time
no frequency drops and the system stayed
cool as well but it was loud now i did a
bunch of testing and i found that the
stock fan curves they're just excessive
you know you're just running way too
loud so i adjusted to max out at 60
percent on the fan speeds and i still
got basically the same performance for
the cpu and even when exporting 8k video
so that impressed me so if you're gonna
buy one of these go and adjust your fan
curves for yourself to lower the fan
noise dramatically now as far as the
gaming performance we have that rtx 3080
just like in the razer but this one you
can actually unlock it to 165 watts i
believe out of the box at 140 compared
to the razer which is like 105 or so and
with this cooling system it could
actually power it and thanks to that if
you are gaming which is a great gaming
laptop you should get noticeably better
frame rate compared to that razer now if
you unplug this laptop those frame rates
drop dramatically and you're limited to
basically 30 fps now you can go in and
disable nvidia battery boost that will
give you up to 60 but that is all that
you can do in order to save battery life
with this system so that just shows us
that this is more of a mobile
workstation kind of mobile desktop
that's lightweight and all-in-one
because in those times when you want
full performance you have to plug it in
now on the flip side actually gets about
six and a half to seven hours of regular
web use compared to about four with that
razor so that definitely does help and
of course the razer also throttles down
if you unplug it now for productivity
when we exported 50 images it was
slightly slower than the razer laptop
with the i9 so as far as cpu performance
it does seem to be slightly slower than
that of course you have the cost benefit
but when you go to something like super
resolution which uses the graphics we
saw a significant improvement thanks to
the unlocked 165 watts for the 3080. i
saw a similar thing for video editing
when we exported 8k video it was
slightly slower than the razer and that
is due to the cpu kind of limiting the
3080 not a significant chunk but it's
noticeable but then when we go to other
tasks that are more graphics based for
example 6k black magic raw it is faster
than the razer and the same thing goes
for other tasks like denoising video in
davinci resolve we do see a noticeable
frame rate increase in that so you are
getting better graphics performance so
overall there is a lot of power packed
into this machine the cpu on battery is
faster than the intel variant when it's
plugged in it is slightly slower and the
graphics is also
faster as well noticeably faster with
that you get better battery life and of
course you get double the ssds double
the ram
in this machine for a much lower price
point and the one thing that i thought
would be the biggest limitation the
display i actually prefer over the razer
of course webcam isn't great the
speakers aren't great so it really
depends on what you're looking for if
you're in this price range i don't know
of any other laptop that gives you
better performance for the money so if
you care about performance you want a
game with the 165 hertz screen you want
to do some video editing photo editing
it packs a lot of bing for the buck
especially if you need windows and you
use programs that are only windows based
so there you guys go let me know your
thoughts on the vector pro down in the
comments section below check out one of
those great videos right over there
click above to subscribe if you guys
want to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we would greatly
appreciate it this has been max and i'll
catch you in the next video
[Music]